why would you come here to see me if you
disagree so passionately with My Views
you've insisted all your lives that the
very concept of God is ludicrous yes
clash between God and Satan ah but I did
not say whose side I was on I consider
what people tell me far less interesting
than what they choose not to tell me
have you frightened off your professor
yet not yet soon
perhaps this was a lecture that a
Harvard teacher named armano Nicoli uh
did he called the adaptation of his
lecture the question of God CS Lewis and
Sigman Freud debate God love sex and the
meaning of life um and he taught it over
the course of 30 years and it was based
on their writings and letters and then
it becomes a play that's right yeah and
that that that course became very very
popular it was I mean it ran for 30
years that's a big a big thing and then
it did become a play written by Mark St
Germain um which was essentially two men
in a room um and having this great
debate uh which I I found really
intriguing especially I mean I just feel
like it's the question of our time but
it's I mean to me I was drawn by the
idea that these two great minds would
actually want to sit down and have this
debate and do it with ra modicum of
respect at the same time so we developed
for a number of years the play into into
the screenplay you're saying people like
Gavin Nome and Ronda santis don't have a
civil conversation no but I get what
you're meaning that this is a way of
finding two people who are let's I
didn't say the you know the
idiomatically agree to disagree yeah
they can agree to disagree and when I
first took this on it was like I guess
five or six years ago and um I just I at
the time I was like things are so
polarized it's absolutely insane and
then today I I think it's that on
steroids Matthew good when you're
thinking about playing this character
there's so much research that's out
there what were the things that you
found the most helpful in understanding
not only CS Lewis but how CS Lewis would
think of himself in that situation one
of the things that's always slightly
worrying when you play someone who's
real who's that I mean he's one of the
great minds of the 20th century so
suspend your disbelief I found actually
it wasn't conducive to me having more
confidence reading more and more of his
work because I just some of it's quite
dense and you know I mean pilgrims
regress is not for the farted let me
assure you um but I but one of the the
things that I found obviously huge you
know hugely uh useful was the book he
wrote in 1955 which was uh surprised by
Joy because it's a memoir about his
about his early life and just how much
trauma there was in it and I think I
mean I loved I I thought it was a
beautiful screenplay and I know that's
uncomfortable for you to hear um but I'm
quite the character is quite reactive I
think he's not inert but I mean he takes
a pounding in there um from Freud I just
wanted to put his Humanity onto the
screen that was that was what became CU
I'm not sitting there ranting and raving
with all all these thoughts and but it's
important to have looked at it and found
it and then as with most things you've
got to you've got to throw it away and
then and almost forget about Tony said
that about playing Lewis many years ago
he said he really did throw that away
and did his own take on it there is a
profound age difference between Freud
and Lewis when they meet and it's the
kind of Gap that might be present
between teacher and student or father
and son so how do you collectively work
against it becoming a pedagogical or
paternalistic relationship what I really
loved was I felt like there was a
friendship that actually emerged over
the course of this and that you almost
sense at the end of the movie that Freud
doesn't want him to leave and Lewis
doesn't want want to go because he knows
it's the last time he'll see him and I I
thought that was kind of beautiful um
even though they still don't see I ey
when you are thinking about the stories
that are unfolding outside of their
meeting you have many options you have
Anna's story Janie Moore the mother of
Cs Lewis's friend how do you decide
which stories you want to tell and there
are stories you shot that you ultimately
didn't quite figure out how to integrate
into the Finnish film I decided that in
the end that um having Anna Freud be the
be story outside of Lewis and Freud was
was most important to to show her
attachment disorder and to have that
going into the third act because that is
a reveal that he that Freud has been
having his daughter in therapy which
today would never in a million years
happened and he also had Dorothy in
therapy um and he wasn't approving of
that relationship so it was very very
manipulative um and uh and slightly
Twisted so that's where I decided to
land on um although the Janie Moore
story is fascinating in and of itself
it's worth noting that Freud was
diagnosed with cancer of the jaw in
1923 16 years before this story and his
course of treatment would prove over to
be incredibly painful 16 years he
underwent 33 operations and constant
recurrences of cancerous sores he was in
agony um I'm going to ask you Matthew
good about creative challenge is was
there a scene that you looked at in the
screenplay where some actors do this you
put like a little note you know this is
going to be tricky or you think about I
think we've covered it we um um that
proved either to be that scene or not I
know having a mental breakdown in a
children's mudro is one thing but was
there a scene of
dialogue that you flagged early that
turned out to be either what you
expected to be or a different experience
I mean they were long scenes so suppose
I
suppose those in just just in their in
their very essence you're like oh it's
seven pages you know you're you're like
well I want we want to get this right
but there was but it was kind of good
challenge it wasn't like oh I'm I'm
really worried about it and as you know
part of my process was making for making
sure for Tony I was I was off script so
I knew that I knew the the entire script
before we shot which was obviously
pretty useful I wouldn't I wouldn't have
wanted to have done it any other way you
know what I mean and Tony that was
interesting for ton actually probably
interesting for you because when you are
of a certain age and it's harder for
lines to to go in and so you gave him
the
dimensions so he was able to he kind of
like Tony kind of came pre-blocked which
is great for me and and it was good
because it was Freud's house so we had
this innate confidence and he found that
that with the with the movement it
helped helped him so incredible seven
pages a day you know with and it's very
very challenging um yeah I want to tell
you I want to have one last question for
you if people in the audience grew up in
California you know when fireworks were
legal there's a warning on the bottom
which said light fuse and get away um
which I like to thank as my motto for
moderating but it's also maybe something
you do in directing when you have actors
who know their lines and you've created
a situation a set where it feels like
they are almost on stage performing how
do you get out of the way
let them do what they have to do and
still get the shots you need you just
keep rolling what were the what were the
things that you did to let them do what
you brought them there to do it was
really important to be able to sort of
fall down on this and then be able to
get back up and I felt like we had a
really I think it was creating a safe
place and an environment that for
especially with that amount of lines and
and Tony being of a certain age to be
able to make mistakes and say we're not
going to worry about this and we're
going to get right back up and keep
trying different things and having that
freedom and that confidence that you
could do that in a safe way that allowed
for creativity to flow when he said he's
creatively generous just Tony is beyond
creatively generous I mean that is that
I've never met anybody quite like him I
mean the the music that we have with the
um scene at the end of the movie which
is the Vienna Waltz was something that
Tony he knocked up he wrote it I mean uh
so we were in a house
heard heard he just piano and writes a I
walk in and Tony's Tony not only a great
actor he turns that he's bloody
brilliant on the piano as where you're
like oh so
annoying but he gave us all I mean we
didn't again we were an independent film
we didn't have a lot of resources and
for him to just give us this music for
free was a big deal my last question is
for you and that's not about it's not
about limitations of budget or days it's
the biggest creative challenge for you
in telling the story that wasn't
governed by resources but governed by
what you had to do in getting the story
told obstacles in telling the tale that
weren't about logistics but about
getting the story out that you wanted to
tell I mean the biggest challenge with
with this is telling a story that has
flashbacks like this and and fantasy
sequences and finding a way to make sure
that the audience can stay engaged with
the two main characters that's that's
the ultimate challenge with it and um we
had a cut of the film uh a little while
ago and it was uh it was longer but we
we were really rushing we only finished
this film two weeks ago three weeks ago
so um it's it's been a bit of a race but
it um it I think we finally got it to a
place where I'm hoping and I hope you
all feel this way but I I hope that you
can engage with these characters and in
this conversation enough where when you
do go to the flashbacks it moves the
story forward um or adds something to it
and and that is that is the challenge
you know when you when you do try
cutting it together just with two men in
a room let me tell you that that gets a
little stale pretty quick even with
actors like Anthony Hopkins it's not
it's not simple you know so and Matthew
good it's just like becomes more
difficult when you have actors like
Matthew good I I hear where that
sentence is going okay I get it yeah no
but it's um that was probably the
biggest creative Challenge and I I I
feel pretty good about it but the thing
is when you have two actors like
yourself and that the one thing you
can't make up or direct is chemistry and
and talent and um and it also comes from
some kindness to one another when you're
shooting um but they had that and that's
what I think is special about the film
so I concur Matthew and Matthew thank
you for making this movie and thank you
all for coming
out